mi fate introdurre questo video vi
andate subito e urlare ma vai su e scena
1 under la che belle uguale sottoposto
ragazzi e questo lo spinner più bello
che mi avete mai regalato gli atti fan
cagliari questo modo più bello
grazie mai lo bello spigolo eccomi qui
basta chiudiamo il video salvo mi ha
appena detto che non si può dare perché
c'è una bambina nei due anni che dorme
al piano di sopra dove non ti ho detto
l'età trova bene quella di più o meno a
quella lavorando e mezzo bene tutti i
ragazzi veneti a questo nuovo video io
sono famiglie e oggi giochiamo af wheels
rating perfetto ah che bello questo
limbo parkour andiamo su riccò dimmi
tutto io faccio mai carsi ormai da tre
settimane in una grotta
meno male che cambia sempre un po è
sempre una perché infatti i video sono
una merda quindi che cazzo me ne frega
un cazzo vuoi tu a lesbica alla fase
anch'io ma l'attesa io gioco a in
capitoli non dormo per ciò che resta
rovato al 100 e passa dice che la ram in
e con i mondiali darà minecraft è
perfetto perfetto per me oggetti la
chiamata tantissime neri facciamo un
attimo il suo livello che l'ho fatto
male perché ero pure fatto ragazzi nel
suo primo toro che non le devi toccare
devi toccare devi stare fermo i denti ha
invitato in questo video lo tutu moderna
io l'ho invitato lo ha capito bisogna
andare piano in questo governo c'è pure
scritto come ristoranti l'ho appena
letto ma perché l'hai fatto anche prima
allora perché siamo
lesbica bravo salvo guadagnato un sacco
di [ __ ] un cristo livello palma
bravissimo ad ora a medico ancora
arrivare i numeri del minas 8 possiamo
fare quello che la bambina salvo si
allena salvo si allena solo volume tutte
le sere seaworld trovo batte del 2
battere questo che sei diventato perché
perché io chi sono e sono ben e giudica
sventato una meta anno a sei tu quella
maturi fragili e deboli sono la base del
muscolare la spada guarda spetta
visto è mai stato bravo aspetta un
passato devo ammazzare prima nostri
bruciano gli occhi e la madonna la prima
volta del giorno mio gioco è capito non
va bene va bene
rimaniamo quasi niente qui altri hard
burn the ball run ragazzi table ram
andiamo in temporaneo sono questo quel
che sta mettendo alcuni in faccia un
vecchio e questo è il mio hobby realtà e
non faccio sport una mente i culi
infatti i vecchi giusto meno male che
non ho urlato questa cosa sono bambina
di sopra l'altra ma utilizzata di salvo
che dice queste cose ma arrivata
quanto schifoso sono attaccati a nudo i
dolci alla pensione e guadagno sicuro
dai non le braccia sono già le braccia
con cascate le braccia
hai visto di quanto la pensione del nodo
del suo cavallo il cavallo o quanto suo
scarso che siano lasciamo che faceva
quando c'è una volta sono risolti
facendo al nono mese fa mentre si fanno
queste cose vedo perché la bambina neri
tanto sono davanti
poi sbaglia o lo sbaglio visse non
cambino il mio stesso punto noi fa
collegioca dalle superato o sbaglio
vince sempre sull ma che lo sbaglio io
faccio giocare perché vince lui un
comfort di chi no no vai via tanto
antico da nessuno anche prima non esci
incazzato e non ci penso perché sta
facendo sto video con gli occhiali sono
le pietre sarà esatto mi sono accorto
solo adesso di avere gli occhiali perché
sta facendo un video con gli occhiali
attenzione battono scacciato che su per
un cono schiacciato il bambino ora mi
sono anche piegato addosso pietro mi
passi il bando per primi gli occhiali
circa sporchissima d argento e una
batteria questo perché mi sono preso le
spade in bocca come subito di castro
chimicamente ma questa storia dicendo
regate e ancora vinto il livello è
difficilissimo su diversi stesso
problema anche se tu hai scelto un
livello difficile ora che un calcetto tu
io non lo foco 3d l'ho scelto io non
sono capace a scegliere i veri usciamo
andiamo un'altra roba
boh torna nisi easy quindi queste parte
pietro maio e quello vai vai se devi
tenere premuto e così sono puliti grazie
mi chiamano ci vedo adesso piano vedo mi
spiego cosa devi fare allora questo
gioco devi tenere sulla bici mille
tasto su premuto in finale adesso su per
andare in avanti wifi pietro bagno da in
più ma forse carattere da bambina donna
centro bravissimo vai tu in via nome lo
dirai camera mini sono gli occhiali per
il suo essere questo livello bravo come
si riparte eccolo ai arrivato lui quindi
deve fare così purtroppo troppo bravo
hai capito
hai capito esattamente quello che veniva
no no no e lì la [ __ ] dio è lì la vera
della regione raggiunge raggiungerà la
tesi bravo piedi pizzo non ami ti giuro
che ti si schianta sul muro non hai
visto
[Musica]
quello che mi aveva esultato risultato
sapesse il fatto la cosa della vita si è
schiantato contro il muro non sono mai
morto così in 140 episodi mai successo
grazie amico che bravo si invita per
dare spettacolo sembra è un impossible
impositivo sono vive di più difficili a
cui scriveva dall'altra parte e tocca
del terremoto farlo questo dopo in farmi
arrivare dall'altra parte abbastanza è
piaciuto lo devi arrivare al tratte
toccare il terreno sopra che non ecco
però però da vivo
similmente la vivo la contenzione poi
faccio provare voi che sono io ho preso
dal vivo
ho preso un arpione per quale motivo
stupido ma è perfetto ha deciso dall
altra parte non hodgkin e lungo in
quanto lei pagato con l'arpione non
hesperion ha sparato niente va bene rob
swing due ragazzi con 20 individuali
questo mi devo attaccare aqap che
perfetto ecco guarda ai calcoli dei
mezzi anche di arancione esatto vendita
bensì un effetto che pietro tu che con
le braccia si stia braccia come le
braccia servono in replica a meno che
non sia questo il traguardo ma la vedrò
fin qui c'è sorpresa come fi senza
braccia come fai a partire se che senza
braccia non fa per lei
i positivi conti non ho fatto niente se
non riesce il solito certamente non mi
sono più aggrappato a niente sono
arrivato al finale non soccombere grazie
grazie al perfetto messi benissimo
grazie ad esso vedo tutto perché gli
arbitri livelli solo con i cazzi di poco
non lo so perché la gente piace il poco
bene mi bruciano gli occhi ma perché ti
bruciano gli occhi ti spieghi perché mi
metti le mani davanti alla tastiera
mentre il gioco questa mi sei fregato
sostenitore frate quasi trinità mamma
l'avventura della mamma mai salvo madre
ma perché vedo macchine comunque c'è un
motivo se non lo faccio mai ora che
schiphol i livelli perché bambino parte
a casa dove intercettava il bambino si
aspetta la tangenziale una strada
appunto che ha mai visto le [ __ ] in
autostrada e lei alternativo cosa state
dicendo la camera il problema attenzione
che ci hanno fatto forti bottiglie e va
bene così ieri mattina i bus che ha
fatto la macabra
grazie ragazzi sono proprio forma oggi
troppo bravo allora ragazzi io direi di
fare l'ultimo perché salvo li sta
scoppiando noi stanno scoppiando gli
occhi e la bambina risolva video a
damiani sopra dormendo da dormendo line
a lei attacco fois che dovrebbe star
titans però con un po meno povere titan
famiglia come mikako addosso poi muoio
subito sapere sta succedendo è infatti
si tipo nipote quando la tipo a prendere
atto che la collana in sé volere via è
vero
lo sa che tutto non ha mai visto harry
potter che problemi a colori questo
animaletto lega complimenti animale di
animali e di merda quante perfetta è un
delfino mi ha mangiato il casco sulle 06
force quando hai a richiesta
salta salta zio no angry birds veroli o
schivati a tutti quanto sono forti e
meglio però non c'era proprio coltivati
questo sono dice mai evitarlo dice ma
poi se queste sasha plugins a volte ha
preso delle paste e quella la prima così
il presunto braccio e ha trasformato in
bastiolo 57 57 raga triplo 57 sogni col
ragazzi miei io direi che possiamo
concludere che questo video perché salvo
sta morendo con gli occhi dietro e rosso
in faccia io ho riscoperto di avere gli
occhiali io credo che questo sia il
video più silenzioso che ho fatto in
tutto il canale quindi gli haters del
cazzo che dicono che urlo come le loro
madri di notte a guardare questo video è
perché con un lato c'è una bambina che
dormiva più rispetto cielo e trasmettono
10 per questo video può essere tutto
chiediamo solo che come al solito severe
momento migliore anche la pagina di non
ho finito di parlare edizione sosta come
si scrive cerchi russi simile ci vediamo
un prossimo pietro da ragazzi
[Musica]